you know I think the issue here is
instead of this how about inventing
something I mean this has been iteration
on iteration about on iteration one of
the great iconic companies that created
things in the last regime is now just
iterating on things and worried about
stock value to the holders instead of
actually focusing on the
consumers I think you know this is not
to Ras Apple Apple's iconic this is more
for all the small businesses I was
talking to my dad today I'm like Dad we
got to do this and this and I had
meetings this week with me in her media
I'm like we got to offer this and this
if you're not innovating new you
can only rest on your morals for so long
and so for everybody who's seeing this
headline and thinking about stuff like
no sales are declining the world is
looking for something new there's always
the next thing luckily they make such
iconic products people are good for now
but somebody's going to come along and
invent some and change the game